what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the 10 lives of wolverine
we had to get caught up on this right
we're a little behind i think we're like
one issue behind on the 10 lives and 10
deaths of wolverine so we'll get caught
up this week or next week whatever it is
but nonetheless right i mean the the
series are they're basically done i
think at this point we got like one or
two more issues of each and then that's
basically it but um what this does right
this one picks up again with uh the 10
lives of wolverine we're really kind of
jumping back and forth through time in
terms of like these these seminal
moments in wolverine's history and this
one in particular deals with wolverine
when he was under the control of carol
hines professor thornton and abraham
cornelius during the whole weapon x
project thing right so when he was
basically having was really being
experimented on being weaponized and
ultimately having adamantium bonded to
his skeleton but one of the things that
happens here is that abraham cornelius
when he's examining the blood sample of
wolverine ends up seeing a kind of
strange uh parasite that he's not really
familiar with which we know is basically
venom now for those of you guys who
aren't really familiar with this uh
during the whole really the donnie
kate's run on venom and one of the
reasons why it was so cool is because
you had this web of venom miniseries and
what it was designed to do was to
actually inject different aspects of the
venom mythology throughout the entirety
of marvel comics that were the
traditional concept was that the venom
symbiote was just a suit that peter
parker found during the events of secret
wars brought it back to earth cast it
off then it bonded itself to eddie brock
and it just been that way ever since
that with uh with donnie kate's run he
actually introduced this idea of like
the king in black and the grendel
different things along those lines that
the symbiotes themselves building on
what bendis had done in planet of the
symbiotes had been around for quite some
time and it actually existed on earth at
some point in time what you also got was
the idea of like basically venom super
soldiers or like grindel super soldiers
really what they were more like symbiote
soldiers but that that wolverine had
been one of those or been exposed to the
venomous symbiote at some point in time
and so that's why you have these aspects
of the symbiote here because what it
means is that he was at one point a host
it was a pretty cool concept right
wolverine becoming venom but as this
happens as abraham cornelius is looking
through all this suddenly omega red
seizes control of him because remember
wolverine's mind is being sent into the
past by professor xavier and jean grey
in order to ensure the survival of
professor x and to make sure nobody
assassinates him but at the same time he
had the mind of omega red which was also
sent into the past by a michael rasputin
using the cerebro sword essentially a
weaponized version of cerebro technology
that can send the mind into the past as
well and so essentially omega red is
trying to assassinate xavier and
wolverine's trying to stop him just
their minds are being transferred to
different people and so the results of
this is that basically omega red's like
i'm gonna kill you bro
and essentially tries to destroy
wolverine because in his mind it makes
the most rational sense that if he can
somehow destroy wolverine before he ever
had adamantium bonded to his skeleton
then in effect it could basically make
it easier to destroy wolverine entirely
right like he doesn't have to contend
with like the adamantium lace skeleton
and having to face off against that
because so long as a single sample of
wolverine's dna continues to exist
potentially he can make a return it just
kind of depends on how his healing
factor is handled right it depends on on
who's writing the story but again you
know you end up kind of jumping forward
basically to world war ii when you ended
up having like those kamikaze soldiers
who were like flying they're flying
their planes into american vessels right
the japanese were and then you also have
wolverine who's basically trying to
counter that then you switch to uh
colombia right back in the 1960s and 70s
when you had wolverine operating as team
x and was ultimately possessed by omega
red himself for the purpose of trying to
kill xavier the difference here though
is that because at this point in time
when he was on team x he was on this
team alongside sabertooth and like
mastodon and those guys is actually a
fight between himself and sabretooth but
with wolverine being possessed by omega
red now under any other circumstance
this fight would be riveting right it
would be just absolutely fascinating
because any of you guys who have been
reading x-men comics for any measure of
time you guys know the most savage
version of saber tooth was saber tooth
in like 1980s comics right like i tell
people that all the time he was almost
animalistic in nature i mean it was just
brutal how hardcore he was marvel's
toned him down a lot over the course of
the last like 30 or 40 years they've
done a lot to change him right they've
made him far more calm and far less
ruthless than he used to be but having
someone like omega red right who is and
really can be every bit as brutal and
sadistic as a sabertooth can fighting
sabertooth man it would just make for an
epic battle here right now instead we do
get something that's kind of interesting
when omega red actually besieges
sabertooth and says hey no no help me
kill charles xavier now one thing to
keep in mind is that at this point in
his life sabretooth doesn't know who
xavier is he doesn't know the
significance of charles xavier he's
never met him as far as he's aware it's
just that guy over there in a wheelchair
he doesn't understand why this guy
matters at all he doesn't understand why
wolverine wants to kill him in the first
place doesn't even know what's going on
with him with him having that weird
omega symbol on his head right yeah
wolverine's got the omega sanction right
whatever it is
he just doesn't quite grab it but
switching back over to the weapon x
facility as you have omega red trying to
destroy wolverine while he's still in
the tank being experimented on suddenly
the venom symbiote manifests and when it
does it overtakes wolverine it turns him
into one of the grendel and then in turn
it goes after abraham cornelius as he's
possessed by omega red now of course
this leads to a mega red basically
abandoning the body but because of you
know at this point essentially
wolverine's just basically feral right i
mean it's kind of operating under the
control of this grendel and just
attacking everything in sight basically
you know abraham cornelius being the
thing that he sees but this is what's
cool here right because when you look at
this story and one of the things that
makes it so unique is that there is a
bit of rewriting going on in terms of
the history of wolverine and one of the
big questions you have to ask here is
how is this going to impact current
storytelling regarding the character of
wolverine the web of venom introduced
the idea of wolverine having had the
grendel at some point along the line and
that was really kind of it there really
wasn't a whole lot to do there and even
here there's not a whole lot of
significance there but take for example
sabertooth saber truth does have his
current ongoing series right now in
marvel comics but if what you had here
is a situation that deviated from the
traditional timeline which is to say
that wolverine and sabretooth and those
guys on team x were in colombia around
the same time that xavier was there they
just didn't really realize that he was
there at that point in time things would
just kind of continue on the way that
they always did right they would have
completed their mission they would have
been brought back to the weapons plus
facility their mind would have been
turned to scrambled eggs they would have
been given new memories and would have
been sent forward from there right like
basically everything you saw from bucky
barnes and captain america in the winter
soldier film right like that's what they
would have done to team x uh instead
what you have now is a whole different
set of events where you have wolverine
here who is essentially just possessed
by by omega red and while sabretooth
doesn't fully understand what's going on
it's not the way the things are supposed
to be so the question to ask here is is
this something that's going to play a
role in the future of wolverine and
saber tooth stories in mobile comics i
have to believe the answer is yes right
i have to believe that is going to be
the case but regardless when you pick up
with these different scenarios right so
lieutenant xavier like professor
xavier's seemingly his uh his father uh
during the events of world war ii when
he was just a lieutenant on an aircraft
carrier and that one of these you know
that sabretooth controlling one of these
uh kamikaze uh japanese piles is gonna
crash into the ship and try to kill
professor x wolverine basically saving
him wolverine's able to save the day
there right he's able to prevent
lieutenant xavier from being killed
thereby ensuring professor xavier's
survival that when you pick up with the
scene where you have a hymn and
sabertooth fighting the sabertooth
actually just just literally tears in to
wolverine himself that when you also
have the scene where you have abraham
cornelius and everything going on with
wolverine that this could very well be a
kind of book and explanation as to how
it is wolverine was able to break out of
the weapons plus facility in the first
place as opposed to the traditional
history that we'd seen which was him
just kind of breaking through his bonds
just kind of you know being lucid even
if only for a brief amount of time and
making his escape that way marvel
seemingly kind of rewriting his history
a little bit but in this moment when
saber tooth and wolverine are fighting
that sabertooth just rips his heart out
and then consumes it and in doing so
basically ends up defeating wolverine
but there's also aspects of this that
are a little important that one of the
things that wolverine says here is that
particularly with this japanese pilot he
says as long as i stay broken the world
stays broken in the kamikaze attack
kinji failed to die honorably and his
obsession with shame and revenge gave
rise to lady deathstrike he says
ultimately the symbiote couldn't be
weaponized because it couldn't be
trained and controlled so dr cornelius
tried dosing me up with adamantium
instead sabretooth killed me and dragged
me back to team x for reprogramming and
in doing so he saved professor x the
clock spins but it always ends up on the
same damn numbers the more i fight the
more everything seems to stay the same
unless i'm missing something unless in
the constant spinning of the clock i've
gotten dizzy and this time it's actually
different right this is really like
seemingly benjamin percy and marvel
telling us we're rewriting the history
of wolverine we're rewriting some of
these significant moments what bearing
that we'll have i have no clue i mean it
doesn't really look like anything that's
happening in this story in terms of
changing wolverine's history is of
particular significance but it's one of
those things where it opens the door
right that door's cracked now and all it
would take was for a rider to come in
and just bust that door wide open and
suddenly we have retcons on wolverine's
entire history i mean that's what daniel
wade did right in the aftermath of uh
house of m when wolverine got all his
memories back we got we got wolverine
origins by daniel way and he literally
retold the story of wolverine it was a
wholesale reworking of the wolverine
mythos and it was pretty cool i think
although not everybody loved wolverine
origins but the important thing here is
that with wolverine's heart being ripped
out that seemingly he's dead right like
his physical form is dead and somebody's
kind of blocking it right i mean his
physical form at that point is gone but
his mind seemed to have gone with it but
the reality here is that's not truly the
case instead what's happened here is
somebody has wrestled control of
wolverine away from jean grey and
professor xavier and when the question's
asked right xavier basically uses his
his mind and realizes like i'm sensing
like something else is going on here
wolverine can you hear me that wolverine
plunges its claws directly to professor
xavier and that's when you end up
finding out that's what that was michael
rasputin's entire goal this whole time
was to basically find a way in to
override the control that jean grey and
professor x had over wolverine and then
seized control of wolverine for himself
which he's successfully done and in
essence it looks like he'll achieve his
goal of killing professor xavier but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end i'm excited
to see how this ends right i think we
have like maybe one or two issues i
can't remember maybe it's two i think
maybe it's a six issue series but
regardless thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace